Speaker 1: Many of you have emailed me and
said David Herschel Walker has finally agreed
to a debate against Raphael Warnock. And I
looked at the video and I have to tell you,
I don't think Raphael Warnock is going to debate
Herschel Walker. I don't really think Herschel
Walker has agreed to anything. When you listen
closely to the video, it seems as though he is
putting in place all sorts of conditions and
obstacles. But let me back up before we look
at the video. What the hell am I talking about?
Herschel Walker won his Republican primary race
in Georgia for the Senate. Now Walker will face
incumbent Democratic Senator Raphael Warnock. One
of the real question marks has been since Herschel
Walker cannot speak, how could he possibly debate
during the Republican primary? Herschel Walker
did not debate and he easily sailed to victory,
basically riding on the wave of celebrity and
to some degree probably Trump's endorsement in
Georgia. So now the question is again, coming
up, is Herschel Walker going to debate Raphael
Warnock? And as I've told you before, Herschel
Walker, we don't know if it's some combination of
CTE from playing football, chronic traumatic
encephalopathy, mental illness. Uh, well,
whatever. We don't know what he really cannot
express himself. He can't explain his positions
on issues. He often is completely unable to use
words to assemble meaning and communicate it in
the English language. He just can't speak. And
there's been a real question as to how how is
this guy possibly going to debate the headlines
a couple of days ago where Walker has agreed to
a debate he's going to debate? Raphael Warnock
let's look at two videos. I don't think he's going
to debate Raphael Warnock. Here is Walker on the
Sean HANNITY Fox News propaganda program. Listen
to what he says. Will you debate Raphael Warnock?
Speaker 2: Well, I'm going to open this up on
your show. Right now, I have a septic debate in
Savannah, Georgia, in his backyard that we can
debate October the 14th in front of a crowd, that
it'll be his people because we're in his backyard.
And this debate is going to be about the
people, is not about some political party,
is not about the press. But the people need
to see the differences between Senator Warner
and Herschel Walker. And what I mean by that,
they're going to see that, as you just said,
Georgia don't want high gas prices. Well,
he voted against the pipeline. Georgia want
to protect our men and women in blue where
he called them names. He call them thugs.
Georgia don't want men and women sports where he
voted to put men and women sports where it is time
that people see the difference. So in October, the
14, I want Senator Warner to be ready because I've
accepted a debate. Then now he can quit talking
and show the people that he going to stand
behind his words and show up for the debate. Okay.
Speaker 1: So October 14th, we don't actually
know that that's a date that's been
proposed or agreed to with Raphael Warnock,
with the crowd. I mean, okay. So so that's another
condition. It will be a debate about the people,
not about a party or the media. So does that mean
that Raphael Warnock and Herschel Walker can't
have a moderator? What exactly is it that Herschel
Walker is saying? It's all kind of weird and it
feels pretty soft and squishy. So then Herschel
Walker did another video. This was very clearly,
by the way, this was very clearly read off of
some kind of teleprompter. And this was the best
take that they got. And again, it's not really
sounding to me like Herschel Walker is actually
going to debate anybody. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: I don't want to debate.
In fact, I just said that
any debate in your backyard.
Speaker 1: Is the same talking point. I accepted
a debate in your backyard. Okay. But has one been
arranged? What does that mean? You've accepted it.
Speaker 2: When you got home field advantage and
it's going to be broadcast statewide. I'm not
a politician. I don't look like a politician.
I don't sound like a politician. And
frankly, I'm Tyler, a politician.
Okay. So I'm not going to obey the demands of
the elite press and the liberal establishment
to stand in an empty room for the debate.
Speaker 1: So to me, I'm hearing if it's a
normal debate where there will be moderators
and like some control of the crowd,
Walker won't do it. That's what I'm hearing.
And quite frankly, it's very difficult to
imagine that his campaign advisers would allow
him to debate. I mean, I understand why he's
not debating, because it would be a disaster.
Speaker 2: That's supposed to be about the people
you see. I don't answer to the press and I don't
answer to Rafael one, not I don't answer to anyone
but God and the people of Georgia.
Speaker 1: So what God has to moderate. I mean,
he's giving himself so many outs here.
Speaker 2: So I assume that a debate
that's about voters, I'm
leaving it immediately behind
and taking my message right to the people.
Speaker 1: So it sounds like basically
he wants it to be a rally. I mean, do we know
that Herschel Walker knows what a debate is
in the political space, like what they look like.
Speaker 2: So they can see the difference between
the two of us. October the 14th in Savannah.
Senator, why not? I hope to see you there.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So that's the best take
they were able to get. And I mean, listen,
I have to tell you, if this guy becomes a senator
over Raphael Warnock, it would be even more.
Destructive in what it means about what's
going on in the United States. I mean,
Trump can at least speak. This guy doesn't
understand a single issue and he and he can't
speak. And then you look at someone like Raphael
Warnock who understands issues, can explain his
perspective clearly and decisively and in a way
that connects to the English language. If voters
vote for Herschel Walker and make him one of 100
U.S. senators, I already think things are sort of
in the toilet in the United States to some degree
politically. But it would be like a 10 to 15
flusher, let's put it that way. If Herschel Walker
is able to win. So I hope he debates. I don't
believe that this is him really being committed
to a debate. And I think his advisers would be
crazy to allow him to debate. Let me know what you
think. Are we going to see him in an actual debate
with Raphael Warnock? Find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. We'll take a quick break and be right back